all i do is watch cooking shows
and they're so delicate and petite about
it i'm like
and i have known each other for a long
time and if you know anything about los
angeles
he you know and california he's just the
king
it just so happened that he had done
this good burger pop-up and had been
involved with keenan and cal
so it was just a perfect storm
being able to create my new restaurant
which is fanboy
it feels super natural and super organic
for the first time in my career
and i was going to open a filipino
restaurant and because of
of the pandemic you know we we decided
to sell
you know provisions in raw meat we
figured
let's bring back a sense of community
and like let's open up a burger shop
that you can also buy steaks and eggs
and bacon and bread
and so that way you know like there's a
personal touch again
um in a time where everything feels like
it's app-based
you know so i feel like the community
has responded really well with amboy
and and what we're doing here i can't
wait
um to make these burgers with you
so alvin we have your classic good
burger
and um you're making the sauce we're
going to talk about what's in it
and then we're going to try the french
onion soup burger oh yeah i'm excited to
reveal that to you
i mean when i was tapped to do the good
burger pop-up
hey i was like yeah hell yeah i'll do it
but
b i like literally dissected the movie
and was like okay this this this
screenshot this is all the stuff that
was open around him while he was making
the the sauce
you want to take me through the sauce
what are you going to show me it's
obviously a mayonnaise based
sauce and it really just starts off with
some mayonnaise
and then ketchup similar to like
thousand island
and there's a scene where he just throws
like chili flakes in it
so i'm throwing a little paprika and
it's also like a deep red color
and then i use pickle juice so it's sort
of like
the dirty martini of sauces
yeah exactly pickle juice and then we'll
take some worcestershire sauce
i love worcestershire and then maple
syrup
for sweetness and that's your secret
ingredient
yeah i feel everyone has that in their
pantry and at the end we just put a
little bit of
onion powder you mix it together
and that is ed sauce let's build the
good burger shall we
yes all right cool so i have
you know the movie has a seated bun
so i had to use the seated bun i've got
the seated bun right here
and you have to sauce them on both sides
i love tips like that
because they can change your whole life
so i
am top bun bottom bun
let's do some pickles then on the bottom
of the bun and building your burger is
super important because
you don't want everything slipping out
of it when you take the first bite
how do i prevent that from happening
alvin
it's all about how you layer the veg
pickles are relatively flat and not
super super slippery like a tomato
so you want to put that as a base and
you can shingle it so it kind of locks
perfect and then i don't know if you
have any red onion or
onions in there i have
red onion put that on top of there and
then we'll take some lettuce
and then put that on the bottom okay
this is so revelatory i have never put
lettuce on the bottom of my burger alvin
and never the lettuce will
be like the cradle oh so then should i
be putting it like a baby's going in
there
exactly and then you get the the patty
with the cheese on it i'm using american
i have to agree with you 100
alvin when it comes to a classic
cheeseburger
it's american and nothing but american
yeah you have to have the melty ooey
gooeyness of american cheese
and then if you want tomatoes you put it
at the top
i will say this is the best looking
burger i have
ever assembled like it's almost like an
emoji
look at that are we taking a bite i'm
down
oh my god that is classic
it's classic it's exactly what you
wanted cheeseburger to taste like
yes and the sauce really creates the
complexity
because it has like spicy sweet
tangy
yes i'm glad you like it
so now i am on to the
french onion soup burger french onion
and burgers make
so much sense it's onions that you cook
low and slow for like two hours throw it
in a blender with a little bit of mayo
and then you put like a couple of
teaspoons of worcestershire sauce
it tastes just like french onion soup
throw it on the bun
i just like made some garlic butter and
i toasted it the bun is now a crouton in
your french onion soup
i'll throw some lettuce on there you
mean for the baby
the baby exactly boom
patty with the cheese on it and i picked
provolone
because usually i would use gruyere
but you know sometimes it's it's hard to
find
and then we're gonna top it with
caramelized onions i don't know if you
have any
up there oh i sure do i wish
whoever is watching right now could
smell this it really smells like
the exact way you think and want an
onion to smell
and then you just top the butt but look
at it
it looks super cool yes
it's beautiful let's take a bite
wow
so many layers to the bite
the good burger right in your face this
with each bite a new door is opened oh
yeah
it's super complex every layer of this
burger
from the bun and everything in between
has its own specific flavoring and
texture
did we nail it or what
it's just so good this is why i do what
i do
you and me for life alvin thank you so
much thank you
i appreciate it yay thank you alvin
you're welcome
[Music]